do begin with major news from Capitol
Hill House oversight committee chairman
James Comer he'll join us in a minute
just detailed a series of explosive
allegations against the Biden family
Syndicate including damning new details
involving yeah Joey the big guy himself
now Comer will be here for an interview
in just about a moment but here's what
we are learning from his ongoing
investigation now this is the beginning
of this investigation this is an interim
report first based on financial
documents reviewed by his committee it
is now believed that the Biden family
and their Associates established over 20
apparent shell companies with no clear
purpose other than to obscure what is
the transfer of money often the case to
Biden family members now most of the
llc's will form during Biden's time as
VP and were used to distribute quote
over 10 million dollars from foreign
Nationals to Biden family and friends
for example now here's how payments from
China ultimately ended up in the hands
of the Biden family it started at a
Chinese State Energy company controlled
by a powerful Chinese National that
money was then filtered through at least
five different shell corporations set up
by Biden Associates now still we have no
idea why this foreign Energy company was
paying Biden and the Biden family we
don't know what they were getting in
return for that money or simply
expecting in return and by the way it's
not just money according to Comer's
report the same Chinese Energy company
also gave Hunter Biden a very large
Diamond during a meeting yeah uh-huh
make no mistake this was not a marriage
proposal and it wasn't just Hunter
benefiting from the these types of deals
take a look
Joe Biden's son
Joe Biden's brother
Joe Biden's brother's wife
Hunter Biden's girlfriend or Beau
Biden's Widow however you wanted to
write that
Hunter Biden's ex-wife
Hunter Biden's current wife
and three children
of
the president's son
and the president's brother
so we're talking about grandchild a
grandchild
that's odd most people that work hard
every day his grandchild doesn't get a
wire
from a foreign National or anything like
that all right so now we've uh yeah
doesn't your grandchild get a check from
China
all right now up to 10 bidens received
money pretty weird right now why was
Biden's grandchild getting money from a
foreign National what work were they
doing in performing or what service were
they performing why was Beau Biden's
Widow who was also Hunter Biden's
girlfriend getting money from foreign
Nationals she is a school counselor and
it's not just China here's an allegation
about money from Romania take a look
Hunter Biden and his associates
capitalized on a lucrative Financial
relationship with the Romanian National
who was under investigation for and
later convicted of corruption in Romania
the bidens received over one million
dollars for the deal
and 16 of the 17 payments to their
Associate's account that funneled the
Biden's money occurred while Joe Biden
was vice president
in fact the money stops flowing from the
Romanian National soon after Joe Biden
leaves the vice presidency
this is a pattern of influence peddling
all right so in Biden left office the
money stopped flowing oh what a shocking
coincidence anyway just so we're very
clear when Biden was vice president his
family was raking in millions and
millions of dollars from countries where
Biden was the point person for U.S
policy we're not talking about England
and France this was money flowing from
some of the most corrupt places on the
on the planet Eastern Europe Russia
Kazakhstan Romania China and of course
we all know about Ukraine fire the
prosecutor or you're not getting a
billion dollars you have six hours to do
it and Son of a bee they fired the
prosecutor investigating his son Hunter
Biden who had no experience with Ukraine
oil energy gas at all whatsoever but
he's getting paid a fortune that's a
good Gig if you can get it now it wasn't
coming directly to Hunter the funds were
passed through one LLC or shell
Corporation after another so so here are
two obvious questions if this was a
legitimate business why would you funnel
money through a shell Corporation and
what were the bidens actually selling
what what goods were they offering what
services did they provide now at the
very least this reeks of bribery
racketeering corruption influence
peddling at the highest levels we need
answers to all of these questions if Joe
Biden was named Donald Trump well you
better believe he would be the target of
a very serious federal investigation but
the doj and the FBI just don't seem
interested I wonder why in fact breaking
today the FBI defied a legally binding
subpoena from James Comer and of course
Senator Grassley they refused to hand
over a document detailing what they
believed to be a credible bribery
accusation against Joe Biden the Pres
then vice president from his time as
vice president and keep in mind this is
not a confidential document now just to
keep track we have at least one
documented allegation of bribery against
Joe Biden from what they're calling a
credible whistleblower Source according
to James Comer and Charles Grassley now
we have bank records we have business
records we have emails from Hunter's
laptop about them whining and
complaining about getting half his
income to Pops we have an email
discussing the big guy getting 10
percent Tony bobolinski had said well
the big guy that's Joe Biden and of
course Hunter whining about having to
pay for Joe's home repairs now there of
course are pictures of Joe Hunter and
Hunter's Business Associates at least
one of those businesses Associates was
offered to cooperate with the FBI and
today new bombshell allegations from
James Comer's investigation uh can you
guess what the media mob was interested
in today the Federal indictment of first
term Republican Congressman he happens
to be my congressman how lucky am I
George Santos anyway way so while
Biden's doj is continuing their
years-long struggle on whether or not to
charge Hunter well it only took them a
few months to bring charges against a
freshman Congressman over a few thousand
dollars in alleged fraud do we have a
two-tier justice system now now this was
fake news CNN's homepage today take a
close look at that you see anything
about Comer's presser you do not and
look at your screen here is how the
media mob reacted to Congressman Santos
as he's leaving the courthouse you have
dozens and dozens of reporters chasing
after a low-level freshman lawmaker it
was a media frenzy shouting questions
surrounding him at the presser and
chasing him straight to his car so when
is the last time you saw this person or
uh Hunter Biden for example you ever see
the media act that way with hunter or
Joe for that matter and get this neither
fake news CNN nor msdnc neither one of
them bothered to play the comer press
conference line live this morning but
they both took the Santos presser in
full now think about this you have the
president of the of this great country
the United States has been credibly
accused of corruption the media mob
doesn't care he's in the media mob
Protection Program they're more
interested in a sketchy first-term
Congressman uh with the arm beside his
name now tonight it's clear America
needs answers did Joe Biden sell out our
country to our enemies for personal
profit for either himself or his family
because if he did the media mob the doj
high-ranking members of the FBI and the
CIA and the oso Pious Democrats in
Congress they don't seem to care less
all because Joe has a d next to his name
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else